- [Instructor] We have spent many videos
talking about the three branches
of government of the United States,
the legislative branch,
which passes the budgets and makes laws.
The executive branch,
which runs the government,
and the judicial branch,
that determines whether
things that are happening
are constitutional or not
and can interpret the laws.
When we talk about these separate powers
and we talk about the checks
and balances they have on each other,
the thing that you might
not have thought about
until this point is how many
employees each of them have.
So I encourage you to pause this video
and just make a guess.
How many employees do
you think each of these
branches have, or more importantly,
which of these do you
think is the biggest?
Well to answer your question,
the great majority of federal employees
are within the executive branch.
We're talking about a very
large number of people.
If you don't include soldiers,
we are still talking about
more than 2.5 million
people under the executive branch.
If you include soldiers
then we're starting to
approach closer to four million people
under the executive branch.
So what you see on this org chart
is that most of it sits
under the executive.
That's because the executive branch
is charged with running the government.
So you have the familiar roles,
the president, the vice-president,
the executive office of the president.
Then you have the various cabinet
departments right over here,
and I could move to the left and the right
so you can see them.
Things like the Department of Agriculture,
Department of Interior,
Department of Commerce,
Department of Justice,
Department of Defense,
Education, State, on and on and on and on.
Then within each of these departments
they can be quite, quite large.
You could be talking about thousands
or in some cases even tens
of thousands of employees.
But it's not just about those departments.
If we go further down in
this diagram right over here,
you see independent establishments
and the government corporations
that are under the executive branch.
Things like the United
States Postal Service,
the Peace Corps, you have
the Federal Reserve system.
These are all under the executive branch.
When you take all of these
things in total together
it's known as the federal bureaucracy.
Now the word bureaucracy might
conjure up some images for you.
You might imagine going to some
type of a government office
and trying to apply for something
and then having to fill
out a bunch of paperwork,
or sit in line and then
wait for something.
And so sometimes it gets a bad name.
Even the word bureaucratic
tends to mean something that is
a lot of process and not necessarily
something that moves quickly
or moves efficiently.
But it's worth noting that
even though a lot of people,
we like to pick on the bureaucracy,
and it is worth debating on how efficient
government is at certain things,
we do need some form of a bureaucracy.
Without a government bureaucracy
you would not have experts checking
on whether your food is safe,
checking on which drugs actually work.
You would not have thoughtful people
who are thinking about how
do we run our military,
how do we determine how we
engage with other countries?
So we do need a federal bureaucracy.
These are the folks that are doing things
like writing and enforcing regulations.
They're issuing fines
if you have bad actors,
maybe a corporation that is polluting
where they're not supposed to.
Now where do these people come from?
Well a lot of times the heads of these
various departments, say
the Secretary of Defense,
who's at the top of the
Department of Defense,
or the Secretary of State,
they are political appointees,
they are appointed by the president
and confirmed by the Senate,
we talk about that in other videos.
But the great majority of the bureaucracy
does not come from what is
known as political patronage.
Political patronage is,
"Hey, you really helped
me with my campaign
"and I think you're a
pretty decent person,
"I'm gonna give you a plum job
"at the top of the bureaucracy."
And even the word plum job,
you should maybe take
it with a grain of salt
because some of these jobs
do require a lot of responsibility.
But the great majority of the bureaucracy
is not from political patronage,
but it's actually merit-based.
These are folks, they might
take the civil service exam,
they might have graduate degrees
in something that's relevant,
let's say if they're working in
the Food and Drug Administration
they might know a little bit
about chemistry or biology
and will often, and no
organization is perfect,
oftentimes people get
promoted for the wrong reason,
but for the most part
they're going to be
promoted based on merit.
So it's completely
reasonable for us to debate
how large this bureaucracy should be.
For sure our federal bureaucracy
is sometimes inefficient,
but we do need it,
and we're talking about
millions of people,
many of whom are experts in their field,
who are really just trying to
help us run our government.